the wastelands is a vast and dangerous
place one that you should ideally never
wander alone it thankfully you have the
option to bring a companion along for
the ride a friend to fight alongside and
someone to keep you company there are
over a dozen companions in Fallout 4
from a dog to a house robot to a cyborg
detective and a supermoon but what are
the benefits to having one well first of
all you can equip them with various
armors and weapons you find and also use
them as extra storage when you start to
get over encumbered you can instruct
your companions to move to different
locations to try to gain tactical
advantages as well as using them as bait
while you take cover to gain your health
back your companions can also help you
inspect objects and sometimes help you
hack a terminal or crack a safe if you
have the right one with you companions
can't be killed but they'll need
stimpaks and if they fall in combat you
have to use a stim pack to get them back
into the fight each companion acts
differently from the other and will
respond differently depending on how you
treat people or what you do in the
waistline to increase your affinity with
each companion you're going to have to
do something different let's take Nick
Valentine for example he likes it when
you hack terminals and when you treat
others with respect as you do this your
companion will like you more and more
each companion has his or her own unique
perks that will unlock once you've got
them to like you or possibly by
finishing and associated side quest for
that companion however if you do things
they don't like
you'll lose affinity with them then
they'll record on you but they'll start
to challenge you a bit more as you tell
them what to do so best to be on their
good side but which companions should
you take and where do you find them well
individual companions have strengths
some weaknesses
one of the first companions we'll run
into is dogmeat
we will find out the red rocket truck
stock he has a keen sense for searching
for things and will alert you when he's
found something or bring along your
trusty robot Butler codsworth who you'll
find back at sanctuary he isn't the
greatest offensively but he's loyal and
he won't let you down don't forget
pressing garvey who will give you some
nice range support with his laser musket
you'll meet them early in the main
storyline at the Museum of freedom
Piper who you'll find on your way into
Diamond City is surprisingly strong with
their pistol and if you can get her perk
you'll gain more XP from speed
challenges and finding new locations as
you progress through the main questline
you'll find Nick Valentine bring him
with you if you're not the most
intelligent person and need somebody to
do some hacking Kate is a nice companion
to have for close-quarters combat
because of a shotgun and she'll help you
pick locks if your skill isn't high
enough
you'll find her after you clear out the
combat zone if you're running into some
trouble with some tougher enemies and
you need some brute force bring along
strong the supermoon who has the ability
to carry more things than your normal
human you can find him at the Trinity
Towers give him a minigun and watch him
mow down your opposition there are more
companions to find but those are a few
without getting into too many spoilers
if you really want to enhance your
companions be sure to invest points into
charisma by leveling up the
inspirational perk your companions will
do more damage and they won't hurt you
if you level up attack dog Dogma can
bite and hold on to enemies giving you a
good opportunity to use your vats to
finish them up and that's a quick
rundown on companions in fallout 4 just
remember whoever you choose to take with
you on your waistline adventure make
sure you treat them right if you want to
get the best out of it and for more tips
on life in the wasteland stay tuned at
Gamescom and check out our fallout 4
show via the link on the screen below